avec quatre à cinq entraînements par
semaine les efforts de jade le corps on
pays et elle a su saisir la première
place du podium dans la catégorie
cadette lors des championnats de france
de cross en novembre dernier quand je
suis parti je pensais vraiment pas faire
podium je visais un top 5 et bas pendant
la cause me suis vraiment senti bien
donc j'ai vu qu'on commence à détacher
des autres filles donc après je suis
parti et
ça a payé spécialisée dans le demi fond
elle a commencé l'athlétisme à 11 ans
performance et chrono surprenant la
jeune femme qui s'entraîne au club de
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines ne cesse d'impressionner
j'ai commencé parce qu'on m'a repéré en
sixième au cross et du coup après je me
suis inscrit au club et je faisais un
peu toutes les spécialités et après on
donne et j'avoue mon spécial ise en demi
fond parce que c'est ce que je préférais
début je suis m'entraîner comme ça et
puis on a commencé à faire plus
d'entraînement a programmé plus de
compet des minimes 2
elle a montré des qualités qui sont
rares
arrate de quelques dixièmes le record de
france sur 1000 m pour sa deuxième année
de demi fond et puis et puis l'an
dernier en cadettes pareil à la sortie
des chronos
très surprenant
ok je m'attendais pas forcément dès que
le coup de feu retentit ça devient ça
devient une athlète qui est très forte
mentalement
qui comme je dis qu'il va à la guerre
quand elle a pas peur d'aller à la
bagarre et de
est d'aller chercher les filles est
vraiment de se faire mal en compétition
véritable espoir pour la suite jade rêve
comme ces exemples gimmi gressier où
hugo est d'atteindre les jeux olympiques
je pense comme tombe de fer regio mais
bon je pense que j'ai le temps et de
continuer à faire des sélections bas à
mon âge le 1500 et les jo 2000 28
j'aimerais bien los angeles chose que je
pourrais peut être dans les meilleures
européennes
ouaip mais european de sa catégorie une
motivation à toute épreuve et des
résultats qui suivent la championne qui
fait jusqu'à trois compétitions par mois
pourrait rapidement gravir les échelons